okay let's get into hatred mail for this
week we've got great hatred for this
week but before we do that I just want
to remind you what hatred mail is
because it's time to make America hate
again hatred mail written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom this week patriot
mail comes to us in letter form and the
question that we arrived at the question
at which we arrived as often is the case
with hatred mail is it's always the Jews
in the end isn't it take a listen to
this dear David your show sucks because
you have an elitist attitude towards
true patriotic conservatives who want to
help this small guy you are the most
divisive piece of scum I have ever seen
you make fake hate mail just to make us
seem bad like we are are nut jobs you
ass
tell your gay Lib [ __ ] co-host Pattie
macfay
to be quiet he is just is so annoying
one last thing let me lay out something
who runs Wall Street Jews who crashed
the economy is 2008 Wall Street so Wall
Street's is full of Jews so that means
Jews crash the economy which means Jews
are inferior scum who can't do anything
right now clutch your pearls and be an
sjw because this is not anti
anti-semitism right it's the truth I
think a dozen spelling and grammatical
errors there go a long one
what total lack of self reflection do
you have when you say the hatred mail
you put up is fake this is an example of
real hatred mail it's exactly the same
as the supposed hate fake Patriot mail
that this guy says we put up we wouldn't
even have to make it up right I mean
there's an ample supply out there unless
he thinks this is just a double false
flag perhaps and oh yeah we created this
one too
this is a double false flag Patriot male
in the way that it's not anti
anti-semitism which is our another new
term that I've not familiarized myself
prior to hearing this atrium male turn
hey treat male into something positive
there's a coupon code hey tree at 40 h8
er IOT for zero which will save you 40%
at david pakman.com slash membership